SPEAKER 1: And I have not only
the pleasure, but the privilege
of introducing Shanthi,
and we're going
to be having a talk today.
So before we get started,
I want to read a quick bio.
So Shanthi Sekaran
teaches creative writing
at the California
College of Arts
and is a member of the San
Francisco Writers' Grotto.
Her work has appeared in
"The New York Times," "Best
New American Voices,"
and "Huffington Post,"
and online at "Zyzzyva"
and "Mutha Magazine."
Her first novel,
"The Prayer Room"
was published by MacAdam Cage.
She is a California native
who lives in Berkeley
with her husband
and two children.
And today, we're going to be
talking about her book, "Lucky
Boy," which follows two stories,
that of Soli Castro-Valdez,
an undocumented Mexican woman,
and that of Rishi and Kavya
Reddy, an Indian-American
couple who live in Berkeley,
California, as well.
Please welcome me
in joining Shanthi.
[APPLAUSE]
So we'll go ahead and
start off by thanking
Shanthi for being here.
I had the pleasure of meeting
with her a couple of weeks ago,
so I'm particularly
excited for today.
But I'd love to just
start with maybe
reading a couple of
excerpts from the book.
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Sure.
Yeah, so I'm going to read
two excerpts from the two
sides of the story.
So one side is--
one of my main characters is
an undocumented, young Mexican
woman who crosses into
California from Mexico.
She's from Oaxaca, Mexico.
And she ends up in Berkeley,
California, not far from here.
So Soli-- I don't think you need
to know much else about her.
She's crossing the border,
just getting close to it
in this scene that I'm
about to read right now.
And she's met a man
named Checo on her way.
She had sort of a romance
on her journey up.
So that's all you need
to know, and here we go.
"It had been five days
since Soli had last
seen Checo, and thoughts
of him, and what
might have happened
to him, jangled inside
her like shards of tin.
Soli and two other women sat
on the bed of a yellow onion
truck, with crates stacked
high to shield them.
Every now and then,
a thin whistle of air
made it through the slats of
the truck and past the crates,
and for those swift
seconds, she sensed
the sweet nearness of the end.
With the air, the morning
light, the company
of calm woman among who she
could, at last, close her eyes,
Soli felt that she
would hold together,
cohered by a single strip
of hope, just long enough
to arrive at Silvia's door.
They stopped twice that day to
piss on the side of the road
and stretch their legs.
Soli slept-- for how
long, she did not know.
She did not dream of
what had happened to her.
She did not dream of Checo or of
the brutish men who came later.
The cave between
her legs was numb,
but her thighs were
sticky and began
to blister in the day's heat.
When she awoke,
the air was still.
A woman named Luz squinted at
her across the mound of onions.
'Where are you
going?' she asked.
'Berkely,' Soli answered.
'Where's that?' 'Close
to San Francisco.'
'You know someone there?'
'Yes, my cousin.' 'Your
cousin have money?'
'Yes, I think so.
I think she has the money.'
Luz shook her head like she did
not see good things for Soli.
A few hours after dark, the
driver stopped the truck
and stuck his head
out his window.
'Get flat,' he called.
'What's he talking about?'
Soli asked.
Luz rolled herself into a ball.
The truck slowed to a
halt. The engine stopped.
'Get down,' she hissed, and
pulled sleeping Fatima from
the bench to the floor.
'Are we here?' Soli asked.
'Quiet, make yourself small.'
Through the crates
in the slats, Soli
saw the flicker of a
dark green uniform.
The flicker spoke in English.
He spoke in English.
'We're here,' Soli whispered.
'Shut up.' Luz was kneeling
beside her and she took
Soli's hand in hers.
She slipped her fingers
along Soli's knuckles
like they were rosary beads.
And Soli prayed
silently, thinking
of her own lost rosary.
Though his words were
muffled by onions,
she knew the uniformed man
was questioning their driver.
Shuffling paper, more questions,
and before she could move,
a stick shot through the slats.
She gasped.
It grazed her skull.
Again and again, it
rammed through the slats.
A guard's iron wand,
trawling for migrant flesh,
hoping to hit
something live enough
to cry out and prove the truck
carried more than onions.
She held her hands to
her head and prayed.
She knew she was shaking,
but luckily for her, fear
made no sound.
Moments later, she heard
footsteps crunch away
and vanish.
The engine started up again,
and they rolled forward.
Luz released a tremulous breath.
'Lucky,' she said.
'A lazy one.'
She looked up at Soli,
grinned, and pushed her tongue
through the gap in her teeth.
'We're here.'
'In the North?' 'America, mija.
That's what they call it here.
We are in California now.'
Soli looked up to the sky--
same blue as the Mexican sky.
She looked through
the truck slats.
This was California, the
United States of America.
She had arrived, and
here's what she discovered.
This place, this
America, this new place,
this streets of gold place,
looked a hell of a lot
like the old place.
America streaked by her
stripped and tender with heat.
She watched it all rush
past through the slats
of the old truck--
the tin roofs, seas
of broken glass,
glinting and breathless
like a fever dream.
America was the dust in her
hair, the wind in her throat,
the sun that shouted
against her eyelids.
Between the slats of
this truck, America
was nothing but a
high-tech, high-speed dream
of trees and houses and fences,
a sliver of interrupted light.
The old folks back home, those
who'd been here and back,
told Soli she would do well
here, that she had the spirit.
They told her to keep her
head down and work hard,
and for God's sake,
keep her mouth shut."
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
So that's Soli.
The other side of
my story is a couple
named Kavya and Rishi Reddy.
They live in Berkeley.
And Kavya's a chef
at a sorority,
which is its own story.
But Rishi is a worker at
a Silicon Valley company.
He does stuff with air
quality in buildings.
So he works for this gigantic
Silicon Valley company
that I made up.
It's called the Weebies.
And it's one of these--
it's a company that just--
it's like a gigantic Amazon
for children's and
babies' supplies,
combined with some
social networking stuff.
So this little bit is
going to be a little bit
from Kavya's point of view, but
then we're going to transition
into Rishi's point of view.
And here we go.
"Despite the clarity
of her desire,
Kavya had no real idea of
what sort of mother she'd be.
The parents around her seemed to
take great pride in their work,
like artisans of a dying craft.
Jogging through parks and
waiting in BART stations,
Kavya had come across
American mothers speaking
French to their American
children, fathers explaining
the physics of
underground transport
to their preschoolers,
property tax
law to their eight-year-olds.
At the farmer's market the
week before, a little girl
had fallen and scraped her knee.
As she stood sobbing,
inconsolable, her mother
knelt down beside her.
'Here, sweetie.
Have some kale.'
The little girl had
taken it, chewed
on the tough, primordial
leaf, and stopped crying.
The stakes were
high in Berkeley.
The toddlers were eating
their cruciferous greens.
There were things she couldn't
know about being a parent
without being one.
This, she sensed from
the way men and women
with children in tow seemed
to have little to say to her.
Parenthood was a members-only
organization closed
to freelancers and temps.
Outsiders could visit
for lunch, but they
tended to leave quickly,
overwhelmed by the demands
of belonging.
But Kavya didn't want to leave.
Kavya wanted in.
For Rishi, the brilliant
bonus of this new world,
this procreative world, was
a sudden abundance of sex.
They were doing it every
day, sometimes twice,
like they'd done
in the early days.
They had sex for lunch and
ate burritos in the car.
They had sex in the living room
and toppled the throw pillows
from the sofa.
They had sex in a restaurant
once, in the bathroom,
and once in a parking lot.
But after two
months, then three,
these trysts began to
feel inappropriate,
like their control was slipping.
He began to wonder what it was
about, all the spontaneity?
He supposed Kavya
was trying to keep
things fun, maybe
even for his sake,
to combat the impatience
that lurked in the shadows.
For three months, Kavya
refused to look at her calendar
or take her temperature, or do
any of the things a woman did
to track their fertility.
'It shouldn't matter,' she said.
It should just happen.
But then it didn't just happen.
After three months of
trying and failing,
the sex could no
longer be casual.
She began taking
her temperature,
tracking her ovulation.
Rishi had been on
board with this.
He would think of it as
a project, he decided.
Project managing
was what he did,
and driving his
management approach
was the Weebies principle,
the Silicon Valley principle
that nothing was impossible.
Impossibility was not
an absolute, but as
shiftable as a heavy boulder.
Trial and error and a
little cognitive daring
were all it took to make
the impossible, possible.
It had worked for PCs,
the internet, smartphones.
It would work for his baby.
Sex whenever became
sex on a schedule.
Kavya felt a sense of
purpose, satisfaction even.
She was taking charge.
Kavya began demanding sex as
Rishi hurried from the house
to catch the Weebus.
She once actually drove
out to the Weebies campus
and showed up at
his office door.
'I'm ovulating right
now,' she said.
'Like, now.'
Rishi had found them
a nap room, disobeying
the strict single
occupant limit.
They'd emerged
flushed and rumpled
in full view few of
his coworkers gathered
at the espresso machine.
Often, from across the Bay,
she'd text him in all caps--
mid-meeting, mid-presentation,
mid-epiphany--
to say, 'COME HOME.
I NEED YOU NOW.'
What once would
have thrilled Rishi
stirred in him a sense of
anxiety, futility, ingratitude.
He felt less like a man and
more like an indentured servant,
keeping up his end
of a shady bargain.
And every time, every month
they tried to get pregnant,
Rishi watched Kavya
grow more brittle.
He thought of himself
as a rational person,
good at compartmentalizing, good
at avoiding flights of fancy.
But trying to have a
baby defied his powers
of reason and
strategy and desire.
He bought into the idea
that hard work bred success,
but Rishi and Kavya
were working hard.
They were working
unnaturally hard at this most
natural of tasks.
Six months passed
and still nothing,
nine months, and Kavya had found
herself at Prithi's wedding.
And now 10-- the gravel in her
throat had grown to a stone.
Every time she saw
a baby or a woman
with a luscious
globe of a belly,
the stone grew
harder and larger.
But Kavya knew this much--
she was a woman.
She was an Indian woman.
Surely a country
with 1 billion people
had produced some capable wombs.
She was going to have a baby.
She and Rishi just
needed to get away
from the theater of failure
that had become their bedroom.
They needed to escape the
chilly corners of their bungalow
and have the sort of
relaxed intercourse
from which babies
seemed to spring.
Her ears buzzed with certainty
and farther inside, her ovaries
winced.
She texted Rishi.
'Napa Valley, this
weekend, spa, B&B--
I'm booking it!'
The exclamation
mark, so hopeful,
she began to delete it,
then decided to let it be."
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Wonderful,
thank you so much.
I don't know about those
of you that heard it,
but I went through the
full range of emotions
from, the powerful, beautiful
descriptive language
in the first one to--
I don't know, the second segment
seemed a little familiar.
I think you did a great job
at capturing the world of tech
in the Bay Area, in general.
So before we go
into "Lucky Boy,"
I'd love to just hear about
your beginning as an author.
What's that journey like?
Did you always know
you wanted to write?
SHANTHI SEKARAN:
I did not always
know that I wanted to write.
I knew that I loved books.
And I think my brothers--
I have these two
older brothers who
are 10 years and 11
years older than me--
I think they knew before I did.
We used to play "Fresh Air."
We used to pretend we were
on "Fresh Air" together.
Like, my brother
would be Terry Gross,
and I would be me,
talking about a book.
And so I think
they had some sense
that this was what I loved.
But I'd spent a lot
of my school years
thinking I was going to
be an English literature
professor, until I realized
how theoretical that field is.
And what I loved was the books
and the language and talking
about that.
So it was really only
when I was about 22
that I had started
writing creatively,
and took, really, just the
first pages of my first attempts
at creative writing and sent
those into an MFA program.
And got in-- got into
one, and went to that one,
and took it from there,
just to sort of see if this
was something that I could do.
And so it was a slow process,
but the love of books
was always there.
SPEAKER 1: I love that.
That's wonderful.
Yeah, I feel like we're
all-- at least for me,
I'm still trying to figure
out what is the niche, what
is the thing to do.
I love hearing from
authors, their journey,
because it ranges
from always knowing
that you wanted to
write to just one
day, realizing that
it's your passion.
And in terms of
genre, did you ever
think about what
you wanted to write,
whether it was fiction or
nonfiction, particular topics--
SHANTHI SEKARAN: I'd always
wanted to write fiction.
I think poetry is kind of scary.
I really admire poets.
But really, there's no
safety net with poetry.
You're really putting
yourself out there.
Nonfiction-- this
was the closest
I've ever come to
nonfiction, as a writer.
So this took a lot of
research, and I now feel
like more adept at nonfiction.
I feel like I can go
in that direction,
but it took a sort
of transitional book,
like "Lucky Boy."
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
so it's wonderful
because it is a fiction book,
and yet there are so many areas
that, when you and I
chatted, you really
wanted to explore to make
sure that you do it justice.
So do you mind telling
us a little bit
about your preparation
and learning
about tech companies,
immigration, the Latinx
experience?
SHANTHI SEKARAN:
Yeah, so I was faced
with this task of writing
these worlds that I was not
familiar with, from Soli's world
to the Silicon Valley world
to fertility issues.
So I started very basic
with some documentaries
and oral histories,
just getting a sense
of what the undocumented
experience might
be like for people, what it's
like to cross the border,
why people feel they
need to leave their homes
and come to America.
It started pretty sort of
straightforward in that way,
and then I started to
just look for people
who would talk to me.
So immigration lawyers,
immigration policy scholars,
adoptive parents, because
Kavya and Rishi end up
being foster parents
to Soli's child.
Yeah, so in all of
these realms, people
who'd undergone
fertility treatments,
just anyone who would talk
to me about their experience,
I tried to get a hold of.
And people are pretty open.
When you're a novelist
and not a journalist,
people are pretty
willing to talk to you.
And with Silicon
Valley, I spent a day--
less, like, a few hours
here with Ann Less,
who's here, and just kind of
went to lunch in the cafeteria,
walked around a little.
I've never worked
in Silicon Valley.
So a lot of--
I think I absorbed
literally 37 details
and put them all in this book.
During those few hours--
and then, just living
in California, it's
part of the zeitgeist.
You absorb stuff, as well.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
that's wonderful.
I couldn't help but chuckle
when you said the Weebus.
Reminded me of the G bus, I was
like, I like that similarity.
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Yeah, I
had all kinds of things.
I had-- we edited it out,
but I had the snack cupboard,
which was called Fweebies,
because it's all free.
And I thought that was too much.
But then, we were outside,
and you called a dog a Doogle.
SPEAKER 1: A doog--
yeah, our Dooglers here.
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Yeah, Dooglers.
Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: This is why
I appreciated this,
because I knew that you
had done your research.
And as I was reading
through this,
I was like, this is so accurate.
You did a great job
of capturing it.
So speaking of
tech, obviously it's
a predominant part of the book.
What role do you think tech has
as an industry in this topic,
in immigration?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: What role
does tech have in immigration?
I've been thinking about the
H-1B issues that have been
coming up in the past few days.
And I see tech as the new--
it is the new
industry in the world,
and especially in California.
And it needs people.
It needs people who are capable.
And we're such a
globalized society now,
that immigration and tech--
immigration feeds
tech, at this point.
And I feel like that's
the way it should be.
And on the other side of
it, being one of our biggest
industries right
now, I feel like tech
might have a role to play in--
I don't know, in having a
say in some of these issues
and issues of immigration?
I'm not all that
actually completely
certain what I think of that.
I don't know if business
should stay away
from politics, if business
should stay away from issues
of immigration or not.
I'd sort of be interested
to hear what people think,
being in this world.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, we'll
have an opportunity
to get some
questions, maybe even
some opinions from the group.
So speaking more
about immigration,
there is a lot of themes in
the book about immigration
intersecting with motherhood
or parenthood or family.
I feel like often in our nation,
we talk about immigration
as an individual topic.
So what opportunities do
we have to view immigration
from that more family or
motherhood perspective?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: So one thing
that I found out pretty early
on is that of our 11 million
undocumented immigrants,
within that statistic, 5
million children in the US
have at least one
undocumented parent.
So we think of
immigration, you're right,
as a very individual pursuit.
America was built on these
ideas of individualism
versus collectivism and
this idea of bootstraps,
and just being your own person
and forging your own way,
which is all very admirable.
But it's worth noting
that these issues--
when we talk about
undocumented immigrants,
we're not talking about
the one immigrant who
crosses the border on his own.
We're talking about
the family that he
might build in the US,
his family back home.
We're talking about
generations, of ramifications
for whatever we decide
to do with immigration.
SPEAKER 1:
Definitely, and I like
that you're talking about
that because we often
think of an image when we
think of immigrant, right?
And it's often the unlucky,
right, or the unfortunate,
or having to deal with
the same struggles.
But we have immigrants
from all over the world,
and they come with
different experiences.
You wrote an op-ed in "The
New York Times" called
"The Privileged Immigrant."
Do you mind talking a little
bit about that article
and how that correlates with
what "Lucky Boy" tells us,
as well?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Yeah, so
"The Privileged Immigrant,"
that came out in November.
And it, basically,
is a discussion
of my own family's
immigration experience, which
was that my parents
came over in the 1960s
as foreign medical graduates.
My dad had graduated medical
school at that point,
and the US was trying to fill
its hospitals with its Medicare
network that had just
been put in place.
So that article sort of looks
at their experience of yes,
being alienated, yes,
struggling a lot,
but at least having solid
work and having a visa,
having a solid, legal
way to be in the US.
And that not only put them
at ease psychologically,
but it allowed them to
put structures in place
in their lives that have brought
them where they are today.
It allowed them to
start savings accounts
and start investing
and buy property.
And we see I enjoy the
fruits of that now,
and my kids enjoy
the fruits of that.
So again, we're going
forward for generations.
And when you think about
an undocumented immigrant,
there are structures in place
for undocumented immigrants.
They can go to a bank
and open a bank account,
but it's terrifying
to walk into a bank.
We saw what just happened
to the first DACA
recipient who was deported.
It's scary to go in and give
your official information
to an institution when
you don't actually
belong here with legal papers.
So it's really hard for
undocumented immigrants,
I realized, while researching
this book to put those building
blocks in place for
a stable future.
SPEAKER 1: And how much of
your own personal experiences
would you say
influenced this book?
Because the first book
that you wrote also
had a lot of your personal
experiences, as well.
So I'd love to see
how much of that
you incorporate in your writing.
SHANTHI SEKARAN: So my
personal experiences--
in order to start
to understand Soli,
I had to understand
her in my terms.
I had to relate to
her as a person.
And so motherhood
is in here a lot.
I have two kids.
There's some material
right after the little boy
is born in this book
that comes straight
from what I had jotted down
right after my little boy was
born.
And then the ideas of
immigration and, particularly
with Kavya and Rishi, these
ideas of ambition and what
parents want for their children
and what it's like for a second
generation Indian-American or
a second generation immigrant,
there is this unspoken--
sometimes spoken-- agreement
between immigrant parents
and their children,
which basically says,
look, I gave up everything
I knew to come over here.
So you'd better do
something with this.
And so failure is not, in
many parents' view, an option.
So that fed into Kavya's
experience in the story
and it fed into
Rishi's experience.
And it also fed into the
narrative around fertility
and being able to have a child.
SPEAKER 1: Mm-hmm,
that's wonderful.
I also know that
when we were talking,
we were talking a
lot about the things
that you learned when
you were doing research.
And particularly, when
looking at the differences
in immigrants, there was
the detention centers
that you observed, and you
learned a lot about that.
Can you tell us more
about that experience,
what it was like to see what
undocumented immigrants go
through?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Yes, so
I trained with a group
called CIVIC Endisolation,
and they do a lot of work
with undocumented immigrants.
They started out sort of
providing legal representation
because when you're
in a detention center,
you're not given
a defense lawyer.
You're not given a lawyer.
It's not like being
a criminal in the US.
So they were helping people
A, find their families,
and also try to get some
legal aid for their situation.
And when I trained with them, I
visited the detention facility
out in Richmond, California.
And it was just--
I didn't get to see where
people were actually living.
And the Richmond facility
is a somewhat reformed one,
people have a little
more room to wander.
They can leave their
rooms when they want.
They have a little more freedom.
But a lot of what I learned
about the detention centers
came from writings,
lawyers who have
devoted their careers to
researching different detention
centers.
And much of what I learned
revolved around the fact
that detention centers
are basically prisons.
They're often within the
prison facility, itself.
But they're like prisons
without facilities,
because it's not
considered permanent,
a long-term solution
for an immigrant,
so they don't give
you resources.
So if you're a
parent in detention,
and you're separated from
your American-born child,
there's nothing
there that allows
you to reunite with your child.
So if a family
court says, OK, we
want you to do this
and this and this
to qualify for
reunification, there's
no way a detainee can
do that because there's
nothing in the center for them.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
So the research behind it--
I mean, I was so impressed
with the amount of work
that went into finding out,
understanding that experience.
And actually, you
were just talking
about this, that the
story beautifully
contrasts two different
journeys of immigrants that
have different experiences.
Our nation often tends to
privilege certain minorities
over others.
And what I liked is that
you were treading lightly.
You wanted to dig deep and get
information about the Latinx
experience, but you wanted to
make sure that you did it well.
So I personally think
that you took the time
and you handled it very
eloquently and beautifully.
And you were-- as
a Latino, I think
you told the story very well.
But did you ever feel--
maybe you were-- and
I ask this as the kind
of contentious
question, in terms
of cultural appropriation, what
is the fine line between being
an ally and telling
someone else's
experience from your
perspective to show
your allieship,
versus potentially
appropriating that culture?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I did struggle with this
idea of appropriation
and whether I was
telling someone's story
when I shouldn't be
telling their story.
So the way I approached
that was, first of all,
to accept the fact that I
would never truly understand
Soli, my Mexican character.
I can never truly understand
the Latinx experience.
the undocumented experience.
So one thing that I eventually
realized that I had to do
was after all the research,
which was necessary,
I had to figure out how
I personally related
to Soli, to my character.
And I eventually realized
that this was, essentially,
a story about a young
woman who became a mother
and who wanted certain
things for herself.
And the fact that she
was Latina, the fact
that she was undocumented--
these all determine the
trajectory of her story,
but they were not
the story itself.
So I was able--
I tried to connect
with her in that way.
And I just had to realize, I
had to accept that I was never
going to do it complete
justice, and I just
had to tread
carefully and make her
as fully fledged as I could.
SPEAKER 1: Well, as a
former Spanish teacher,
your pronunciation of all the
names is absolutely beautiful,
so I do want to say that.
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Really?
Oh, good.
SPEAKER 1: It made
me very happy.
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Great.
SPEAKER 1: So obviously,
the topic of "Lucky Boy"
is very timely, not only
internally here at Google,
but domestically and
globally, particularly
in the last few months.
What struggles or
obstacles do you
feel you face as an author
writing about this topic
today, in 2017?
SHANTHI SEKARAN:
Struggles as an author--
there was this looming question
of cultural appropriation.
That's a big issue
for us right now.
I did sort of wonder,
initially, if this book was
going to be sort of taken up.
I'm not-- it's not your
classic American novel
about people in Upper
East Side Manhattan.
In fact, the people
who are white,
they're sort of on the
periphery of this book.
And so I did wonder if that--
if the fact that I had
this group of brown people
and this brown woman,
and everyone was brown,
if that would be sort of
an obstacle to getting it
published.
And at one point, I
said to my agent--
it wasn't getting published,
it went through two or three
rounds of rejections.
And I said to my agent,
maybe I should just
make all my Indians white
and see what happens.
And she was like,
absolutely not.
SPEAKER 1: Uh, amen to her, wow.
SHANTHI SEKARAN:
She was like, no.
Well, she pointed out to
me that this is not just
about a Mexican woman.
This is a story of immigrants
on American soil in 2000--
whatever it was then--
2000, the 2000s.
And so that allowed
me to sort of take
a new perspective on what
I was doing, so yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Wonderful.
So in looking into your
future endeavors, what's next?
It could be a
specific book, or do
you think you've found
your area and you
want to continue talking about
the immigrant experience?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: I kind
of want to do both.
So I'm going to start slowly
working on it on my next book
as soon as all
this touring ends.
And I also feel like, you
know, I've written this book,
so this is what
I'm grappling with.
I've written this book.
It's about this topic.
What, am I just going to drop
it now and talk about something
else next?
Because I feel like now
that I've written this book,
I want to do something
more with it.
I want to actually
use it in some way
to enact some
beginnings of change
in something that I care about.
So hopefully, I'll do that.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, and
just out of curiosity,
obviously, you're a writer.
We're all super
excited that this book
is out, nothing but
positive feedback,
at least that I've seen.
But what are some of
your favorite authors?
What do you like to read?
Who do you look up
to, who inspires you?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: My
favorite author--
so for this book in
particular, I really
looked to "Beloved" by Toni
Morrison because for one thing,
on a technical level, I was
trying to figure out how
to work with past and present.
And in "Beloved," Toni Morrison
does this beautiful job
with memory, where she passes
seamlessly from the present day
narrative into her character's
days as a slave and her journey
up north as a slave.
And when I was writing
this, I literally
had my little notebook.
It was on the 20th
revision, or whatever.
I had my little notebook, and I
would copy out Toni Morrison's
sentences just to
sort of understand how
she made those transitions--
so "Beloved" by Toni Morrison.
I really like Zadie Smith.
She's a British writer.
And Anne Enright, her book, "The
Green Road" kind of influenced
this.
I like reading
writers whose voices
are very different from my own.
It loosens up something
in me, creatively.
SPEAKER 1: Wonderful.
Well, we definitely want to
give the audience an opportunity
to ask questions.
AUDIENCE: I haven't
read your book yet,
but I look forward to it.
But I hear you telling the
stories of two brown women who
have had the experience of being
immigrants or second generation
immigrants in America.
And then I hear
about your op-ed,
which talks about "The
Privileged Immigrant,"
and then obviously, the
flip side of that is
the unprivileged or
underprivileged immigrant--
[COUGHS] sorry.
So I was just wondering
what you think--
why you think those
two narratives
that sound so
similar at their root
have developed so
differently in America,
and what we can learn
from deconstructing those?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: So
the two narratives,
they have evolved very
differently on American soil.
To some extent, it's not
a matter of what country
you come, from it's a
matter of the structures
that you've been able to
put in place for yourself.
So if we talk about my
characters Kavya and Rishi,
they own this little
house in Berkeley.
They were able to buy that
house because their parents were
able to help them
buy that house.
And I never really go into what
their parents did for a living,
but the assumption
is that their parents
were similar to my parents.
They came over in the '60s,
'70s, had good stable jobs,
were able to accrue
some savings.
And then, if you have
someone like Soli,
she sort of kept her
money in her home.
She wasn't able to invest.
And so much of this--
so much of this just comes
down to the technicalities
of money and land and the
neighborhoods and the schools
that you're able to
send your children to.
And I guess the choice--
I guess really, what
it comes down to,
is the power to choose
where you want to live
and what you want
to do with your life
and for your children.
And I think that that
really has informed
the various trajectories
that we see in the US.
SPEAKER 1: Just very quickly,
particularly on that point,
in the op-ed in "The New York
Times," you mentioned that it's
not one immigrant group is
better or stronger or more
competent than the
other, but rather,
the opportunities
or the path that
was already created
for them in this nation
before they come here.
So I think that distinction
that you made was beautiful.
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you
live in Berkeley,
and you've written
a book about a topic
that, in some parts of the
country, kind of like plays
better, is better
accepted than maybe
in other parts of the country.
And I'm curious if you're going
to other parts of the country
and if, in those places,
is this more or less
of like a political novel?
Is there some sort of
statement about that
based on where you are,
who you're even talking
with or talking to about it?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Yeah,
so whether or not
this is a political novel,
that usually comes down
to the individual reader.
So people who really
want to engage
with the political
aspects of this,
they'll talk to me about that.
And some people are just not
very politically engaged,
and so they see it for
the interpersonal drama
of the book.
And in terms of traveling to
different parts of the country,
I've been mostly
on the West Coast,
and then, New York and DC,
but I did go down to Dallas.
And I've been waiting for
the person with the red hat
to stand up and ask
me some questions,
but they haven't yet.
I find if--
I assume that there is dissent.
I assume that there
are going to be
people around who
don't like what
I'm talking about in this book.
But they haven't
said anything yet.
And I think that,
like a lot of us,
when they don't like something,
they're keeping quiet
or they're just not
thinking about it.
So that's--
AUDIENCE: How would
you respond to that?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: How would
I respond to that dissent?
I'd first want to know
if they read the book.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Fair.
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Because
I feel like if you--
when you engage
with someone's story
and you really sort of connect
to them as a character,
you start to see things
in a more complex way
than you would normally.
And I guess I would
want to listen
to where they're coming from.
I'm not the sort
of writer who can
get into a political
argument with the reader.
But I could talk to them about
the issues within the book.
And really, I can't pretend
to want to convert people,
but I want people to
understand that this
is a more complex
situation than they
may have initially assumed.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious-- you
mentioned that you're a teacher
and you're a mother and you
wrote this book, obviously.
I'm just curious how
you structured your time
and what a day in the
life is like when you're
working on a book like this
that requires so much research
and time and engagement?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Right,
yeah, so it was very slow.
I should say I wrote
most of it when
I had just one kid, not two.
Because when you have two,
it's like you have 1,000.
So basically, what I would
do is I would drop my kid off
at preschool.
I was teaching at the
same time, but only
part-time at an
art college at CCA.
And so I would drop my
kid off at preschool,
take BART into San Francisco.
I used to go to the Writers'
Grotto in San Francisco
to write a lot.
So I'd have one or two
days where I would just
spend the day there, and then
be back in Berkeley for the 4:00
PM pickup at preschool.
And so I had a couple of
days like this per week
that were just completely
devoted to the book.
And slowly, slowly it builds.
And at a certain point, you
get enough into the book
that you can just write
anywhere at anytime.
You know, you can be standing
on a bus and writing, so yeah.
AUDIENCE: How long did
the whole thing take you?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: How long
did the whole thing take?
So it took about 2 and
1/2 years for one draft.
And then there was about 3 and
1/2 more years of reworking it
and editing.
Yeah, yeah, that was a
lot slower than I thought.
I thought I'd like, write it,
and it'd be ready, but no.
AUDIENCE: I haven't
read the book,
but I'm curious, how
do you sit on the title
when there's these paths
of luck and un-luck,
depending on the
different journeys
and where their characters are
in their stages of their lives?
SHANTHI SEKARAN:
Yeah, so the title--
I never thought of lucky as--
in terms of the
characters' journeys,
but I guess it
does apply to that.
So "Lucky Boy"
refers, primarily,
to Ignazio, who's a
little boy born to Soli.
And it has sort of an ironic
side, but also a sincere side.
He's sincerely lucky because
he has these two mothers who
love him and want him.
And he's not so
lucky because it's
this love that sort of
pulls apart his destiny.
He doesn't know where
he's going to land,
or we don't know where
he's going to land, really.
And in terms of
picking the title,
I think this was maybe
the fifth or sixth title
that I settled on.
SPEAKER 1: Can we ask what
some of the other titles were?
SHANTHI SEKARAN: Oh, yeah, so
I think the first one, when
I didn't really know where
this was going completely,
was "Our Winning Smiles," which
is from the Belle and Sebastian
song.
I just-- I liked it.
And then, there were
some not so great ones.
But one of the other major
ones was "Season of the Beast,"
because I--
that image of the
beast comes up a lot,
but also there's
La Bestia, which
is the freight train
that migrants ride up
through Mexico.
They ride the top of it,
and it's pretty dangerous.
That's in here, as well.
And at one point--
this is bad.
So at one point--
Ignazio's nickname that his
mother gives him is Nacho.
So at one point, it was
"Nacho!"-- exclamation mark.
And then, eventually,
there is this one line
that has the phrase
"Lucky Boy" in the book.
And so eventually, I was like,
oh, OK, I'll just go with that.
And my editor wanted to change
it, and then we decided not to.
SPEAKER 1: So thank
you so much for coming.
We had a blast.
We really appreciate it.
SHANTHI SEKARAN:
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]